alors le secret pour avoir des milliers
d'abonnés pour faire des millions de
vues eh ben ce secret n'existe pas voilà
c'est l'anti climax connais par contre
vu que je suis sur youtube depuis un
petit moment et j'ai quand même quelques
petits conseils à vous donner surtout
quelques erreurs à absolument éviter
mais tout ça ça sera après l'intro
[Musique]
et salue les gens derrière l'écran c'est
françois pour la chaîne explique moi
encore je suis ravi de vous retrouver
comme à chaque fois pour une nouvelle
vidéo mais avant toute chose si vous
êtes nouveau sur cette chaîne
ici on parle de vidéos de tournage de
montage de matos bref tout ce qui a
rapport avec la vidéo donc si ça vous
plaît vous pouvez envisager de cliquer
sur le petit bouton s'abonner qui se
situe juste en dessous de cette vidéo il
y aura très probablement des choses qui
vont vous intéressez sur cette chaîne
est dans la vidéo d'aujourd'hui si vous
avez déjà une chaîne youtube ou si vous
envisagez d'en créer une
il est plein de choses dans cette vidéo
qui vont être pour vous mais juste avant
de démarrer je tiens à dire que ce que
je vais vous faire ici c'est un retour
de mon expérience une chaîne à 60 mille
abonnés au moment où je fais cette vidéo
donc pas forcément non plus une chaîne
extraordinairement développer mais qui
fonctionne quand même plutôt bien et ben
ça fait environ trois ans que je fais ça
à peu près sérieusement donc bah j'ai
commis quand même pas mal des reins et
ça je vais vous le partagez et en
complément si vous voulez avoir une
chaîne qui analyse de manière très très
très rigoureuse voire même scientifique
un petit peu le fonctionnement de
youtube je vous encourage à aller voir
le coin des youtuber j'en ai un lien
dans la description chaîne tenu par
sylvain qui fait des choses
extraordinaires est vraiment un travail
de très très grande qualité mais les
conseils qui vont suivre ce sont des
conseils de fond et vous allez voir
qu'il ya sûrement des erreurs que vous
faites vous aussi et qui va falloir
éventuellement corriger si vous avez
envie que les choses se passent plutôt
bien allez c'est parti on rentre tout de
suite dans le vif du sujet la première
chose à faire et peut paraître évidente
et pourtant c'est pas forcément le cas
pour tout le monde cette chose c'est de
faire sur youtube quelque chose que vous
aimez et surtout que vous savez faire
grosso modo la thématique de votre
chaîne ça devrait être le truc dont on
vous parle en disant à 10 ans montait
doué pour ça c'est chouette ce que tu
fais pourquoi je vous dis ça et bien
tout simplement parce que très souvent
quand on veut se lancer sur youtube
parfois bon il ya ce côté passion aussi
mais il ya le côté paillettes le côté
renommée célébrités on a envie de
montrer de plaire il faut faire très
attention avec ça parce que c'est
quelque chose qui peut vous détourner de
l'objectif premier
alors on reviendra sur ce truc oui mais
il faut faire que du youtube par passion
parce que c'est pas complètement vrai
non plus mais en tout cas l'idée c'est
que il faut se lancer sur quelque chose
qu'on sait faire et pour lequel on a
déjà une petite reconnaissance au moins
par notre cercle d'amis par nos proches
parce que si du jour au lendemain on se
dit tiens je veux être gamer où je veux
être humoriste alors qu'on n'y a jamais
touché
c'est peut-être pas encore
le moment de se lancer dans mon cas je
me dis que aujourd'hui j'ai les
compétences techniques pour faire ce que
je fais sur ma chaîne youtube et
expliquer des choses ce qui n'était
peut-être pas tout à fait le cas au tout
début j'ai appris plein de choses
bon j'ai pas dit trop de conneries tout
au long de mes vidéos je sais quand même
de me documenter mais il ya des choses
sur lesquelles j'ai changé d'avis avec
le temps et si je devais refaire
certaines vidéos que j'ai fait à mes
débuts je leur ferai pas pareil
forcément
la deuxième erreur qu'on pourrait
potentiellement faire c'est aussi de
vouloir trop respecté les codes de
youtube à force de vouloir trop respecté
les codes ont fini par un petit peu bas
d'être noyé dans la masse parce qu'on se
ressemble un petit peu tous j'avais
traité d'ailleurs du sujet dans une
vidéo qui s'affiche quelque part
au-dessus respecter les codes c'est
important parce que un contenu qui est
vraiment trop différent de ce que les
gens ont l'habitude de voir sur youtube
habituellement bah c'est pas forcément
un contenu qui va être vu beaucoup mais
a contrario un contenu qui va être trop
similaire à ce que tout le monde peut
voir là aussi il ya tellement de monde
sur youtube
aujourd'hui que c'est difficile de se
démarquer si notre contenu
il est trop formaté d'entrée de jeu il
ya bien sûr un public pour les formats
très formaté justement très youtube est
ce qu'il ya aussi un public pour les
gens qui veulent quelque chose de
totalement différent mais idéalement
quand on se lance l'idée c'est d'essayer
d'être à peu près à mi-chemin entre les
deux le troisième conseil ou plutôt la
troisième erreur à éviter c'est selon
moi d'éviter de faire des vidéos
d'humeur ou des coups de gueule alors ça
veut pas dire qu'on peut pas dire ce
qu'on pense ou qu'il faut être lisse ou
consensuelle sais juste que quand on
fait une vidéo d'humeur souvent on l'a
fait un petit peu bain sur l'impulsion
et ça peut avoir un effet très
contre-productif ce qu'il faut se dire
c'est que les gens la plupart du temps
même si c'est pour apprendre qu'il
vienne sur une chaîne c'est aussi pour
se divertir et pour passer un bon moment
donc si en face ils ont un mec qui est
vener qui est pas de bonne humeur bon ça
peut passer de temps en temps mais si
c'est récurrent clairement on va plus
avoir envie d'aller voir quelqu'un qui
tire la gueule quoi tout simplement
amener plus tôt du contenu constructif
et puis si vraiment vous avez envie de
pousser un coup de gueule parce que
c'est quelque chose qui vous pèse et
quelque chose que vous avez envie de
partager une réflexion que vous avez
envie de partager avec les autres
laisser passer un peu de temps ici
quelques jours ou semaines plus tard
l'envié est toujours là et si vous avez
un petit peu construit le déroulé de
votre vidéo pour l'argumenter
correctement dans ce cas là peut-être
que ça vaudra le coup effectivement de
faire un petit coup de gueule
une vidéo d'humains mais évitez d'une
manière générale de faire des vidéos ah
tiens j'ai une idée pas j'aime la caméra
j'y vais c'est assez rare de sortir du
contenu de qualité comme ça direct sur
une impulsion une erreur suivante est
celle là je pense qu'on la fait tous un
petit peu parce qu'on se voit le tous un
petit peu la face c'est de ne pas
assumer de vouloir faire des vues ça
c'est quelque chose que je pense être
très très très important d'après moi si
on met du contenu en ligne public sur
youtube c'est pour qu'il soit vu alors
oui on a une passion on a quelque chose
à partager
mais à partir du moment où on le rend
public pour moi c'est parce qu'on veut
que ça soit vu par d'autres et qu'on
espère aussi que ça plaira à des gens
d'en mettre un contenu exprès pour
déplaire à des gens ou alors c'est
bizarre mais voilà il faut pas être
hypocrite on a tous envie que nos vidéos
soient vus pas à tout prix pas en
faisant ce qu'on appelle du pit à
cliquer ou en faisant du des titre
mensonger ou en trichant
mais on a quand même envie que nos
vidéos elle ait du succès et ça je pense
qu'il faut l'assumer pleinement et ça
passe par le fait déjà de le savoir de
se dire j'ai envie que mes vidéos belle
soit vu par le plus grand nombre et
qu'elle soit appréciée parce que
j'estime que je fais du contenu de
qualité
donc à mon avis faut pas hésiter à
mettre des titres aguicheur alors je dis
pas mensonger mais des titres qui
donnent un petit peu de suspense qui
donne envie de cliquer sur sur la vidéo
les miniatures pareil
quelque chose qui soit un petit peu
intrigant et qui donne envie d'aller
voir le contenu sans pour autant faire
quelque chose de totalement mensonger ou
de vraiment pas cool j'ai eu de temps en
temps cette discussion demandé dans les
commentaires ou en message privé des
gens qui disaient à l'attention de ton
titre il est un peu plus ta clique mes
titres sont pas mensonger des titres qui
font en sorte que vous ayez envie de
cliquer dessus et ça pour moi c'est
totalement normal c'est assumé et ça
devrait être pareil pour tout le monde
et quand on voit la masse de vidéos et
de créateurs qui lie à se priver de ça
c'est vraiment dommage parce que ben on
le sait très bien
le titre et la miniature ça y est pour
beaucoup dans le succès ou pas d'une
vidéo donc assumé de vouloir que vos
vidéos soient vus parce que c'est
absolument pas quelque chose de mal
c'est absolument pas malsain bien au
contraire c'est logique dans votre
démarche de création de vidéos et de
mise à disposition publique de ses
créations là pour tout le monde une
autre erreur à éviter
et de faire très attention aux chiffres
parce que forcément si vous avez votre
chaîne ou si vous allez la craie et vous
allez télécharger les youtube studio qui
va vous donner tous les analytics tous
les chiffres qui concernent votre chaîne
et je vous encourage à aller voir le
documentaire sur netflix qui s'appelle
derrière nos écrans de fumée moi j'en
avais déjà conscience un petit peu avant
mais là le documentaire m'a fait une
presque une révélation dites vous quand
même que youtube et c'est normal c'est
une entreprise qui cherche à faire du
profit ce qui est totalement logique
vous pousse au travers de la façon dont
les analytiques sont foutus à créer
toujours plus de contenu et à vouloir
toujours faire plus de vue c'est fichu
de manière à vous dire que si vous avez
une vidéo qui marche moins bien que la
précédente
bah quelque part vous avez un petit peu
faute et donc il va falloir régler ce
problème là et à la prochaine vidéo
faire plus de vue qu'à la précédente
ces fichus exactement comme ça donc mon
conseil c'est déjà ne pas avoir youtube
studio sur votre smartphone comme ça
vous n'êtes pas tenté d'aller le voir
si vous n'avez pas d'ordi la disposition
vraiment si jamais il ya quelque chose
qui doit être fait dans la seconde
pouvez toujours la télécharger et faire
ce que vous avez à faire mais ne pas
regarder les chiffres trop souvent moi
par exemple je sais que généralement je
vais les voir trois quatre fois par
semaine je reste un petit peu plus les
jours de sortie de vidéos pour répondre
aux commentaires pour voir un petit peu
comment la vidéo démarre mais au bout
d'une heure après une sortie de vidéos
je coupe tout et puis je regarde le
lendemain ce que ça va donner mais ces
chiffres là c'est important de les
comprendre pour essayer de faire
fonctionner sa chaîne correctement mais
il faut pas se laisser avoir parce que
c'est un système un petit peu pas
vicieux mais mais pas loin il va vous
pousser à faire toujours plus et
éventuellement vous faire perdre de vue
encore une fois vos objectifs de départ
qui était ce qu'il était c'est à dire le
partage la création
je ne sais quoi tient d'ailleurs en
parlant de chiffres et de codes dont on
a parlé un petit peu avant c'est le
moment où je vous demande d'aller
cliquer sur le petit bouton s'abonner si
cette vidéo vous plaît pour faire monter
ses chiffres que je ne verrais que dans
quelques temps puisque je ne les regarde
pas tous les jours dit le petit
s'abonner le petit pouce en l'air si ça
vous plaît voilà ça coûte rien une
erreur qu'on peut souvent comme être
aussi c'est de vouloir toucher tout le
monde
aujourd'hui c'est quand même très très
compliqué d'avoir une chaîne qui touche
énormément de gens avec des sujets qui
sont plus ou moins universel il ya déjà
beaucoup de monde dans la place il ya
déjà beaucoup de créateurs qui font ça
très très bien et qui occupe beaucoup
d'espacé
je dis pas que c'est impossible mais
c'est quand même plus difficile dites
vous bien que quand on est dans une
niche quand on traite d'un sujet très
spécifiques ben on a potentiellement
plus de chance que la chaîne fonctionne
que votre chaîne youtube fonctionne
plutôt que si vous essayez vraiment de
toucher trop de monde par exemple ici je
sais très bien que traitant de la vidéo
je vais toucher quand même une part
minime de la population qui est sur
youtube
contrairement à des humoristes ou à des
gamer dont le public est beaucoup plus
nombreux y'a qu'a voir en france les
plus gros youtuber qui sont sur cette
niche de la photo de la vidéo font pas
des scores à la hauteur des youtuber de
même niche anglo saxons par exemple mais
ça il faut en être conscient donc soyez
précis dans le choix de la thématique de
votre chaîne et n'hésitez pas à aller
vraiment dans une niche en vous assurant
que vous aurez la possibilité de créer
du contenu sur du long terme sur cette
niche là un autre truc à éviter
absolument c'est les boosts par des
grosses chaînes ça fait très très
attention avec ça parce que je vois
souvent des gens qui demandent à des
gros youtuber de mettre en avant leurs
chaînes et tout pour pour la faire
exploser
alors pour moi il ya rien de pire que sa
propre ruine et une chaîne pourquoi
parce que les abonnés de ce gros cube
heures qui va vous mettre en avant déjà
ils sont peut-être pas dans la même
thématique que vous comme si je
demandais à timbo in shape de me faire
de la pub je me récupérer des gens qui
n'ont strictement rien à de la
vidéo est donc pas qu'ils vont s'abonner
pour faire plaisir à leurs créateurs qui
est leur a demandé mais qui viendront
pas voir mes vidéos et qui vont du coup
me pourrir la lgo parce que la lgo
pensera que
vidéo sont de moins bonne qualité
puisque les gens ne viennent pas les
voir donc la croissance naturelle il ya
que ça de vrai ou alors les
collaborations avec d'autres youtuber
qui sont dans le même créneau que vous
mais évitez d'aller taper aux portes des
très gros youtuber finalement si vous
vous êtes la pub ça pourrait être très
très très très contre-productif pour
vous parce qu'au final même si vous avez
de la pub à un moment et un énorme boost
d'abonnés sur le long terme ça
fonctionnera pas bien ah et puis un
conseil simple ne dit pas ce que vous
allez faire fait le voilà je vais être
très court très simple pas la peine de
dire bientôt je vais faire ça je pense
faire si et j'aimerais bien faire ça et
machin en fait le juste
voilà une erreur aussi qui en lien avec
ces boost de grues youtuber c'est de
penser qu'il ya des éléments extérieurs
qui influent sur le succès ou pas de
votre chaîne youtube oui il ya forcément
des choses qui vont plus ou moins joué
mais le plus important ça reste le
contenu que vous proposez la régularité
de ce contenu et la qualité de ce
contenu c'est vraiment les choses les
plus importantes c'est vraiment sur ça
qu'il faut s'attarder
tout le reste c'est accessoire ça peut
aller ça peut venir peut y avoir des
pics à certains moments c'est pas trop
pourquoi il peut y avoir un partage
d'une personne qui vous fait un peu de
pub mais le plus important ça reste le
conte est un autre conseil tout simple
et est très court
garder le cap il faut il faut se battre
il faut avoir envie il faut essayer
pendant un moment de faire en sorte que
ça fonctionne mais si au bout de
plusieurs années à chaque vidéo vous
sortez vous faites 10 vue d'être aussi
se dire qu'il ya un moment où si ça
marche pas ça marche pas 1 c'est
peut-être pas fait pour vous non plus je
sais que c'est pas facile des fois à
entendre ce genre de choses là mais
voilà ça peut aussi vouloir dire ça si
ça marche pas enfin la dernière erreur à
ne pas connaître c'est tout simplement
de ne pas se laisser manger par youtube
on en parle est un petit peu avant
youtube c'est quelque chose de très
chronophage on a toujours envie de faire
mieux de faire plus d'y passer du temps
d'être au top et de produire énormément
de contenu mais ça peut prendre un temps
monstrueux n'oubliez pas qu'il ya
d'autres choses à côté que même si c'est
votre métier ou en partie votre métier
comme c'est le cas pour moi il ya
d'autres choses à côté et youtube ça
peut vous bouffer le cerveau totalement
donc mon conseil c'est à louer vous un
temps dans la semaine que vous consacrez
à youtube
essayez de ne pas déborder de vous dire
voilà je me consacre une journée je me
consacre une demi journée je me consacre
deux heures par semaine à youtube il pas
plus en fonction bien sûr de la taille
de la chaîne des retours que vous avez
des interactions que vous allez avoir
parce que ça aussi les commentaires les
messages en privé ça prend énormément de
temps et puis on oublie souvent de se
dire tiens baissé voilà ça fait partie
de mon boulot sur youtube
il n'y a pas que la création de vidéos
il ya tout le reste qui va avec
donc alloué vous une plage et essayer de
respecter adapté mais gardez en tête que
il ya aussi plein de choses autour ya
pas que youtube dans la vie et vous
savez ce qui est cool aussi dans la vie
c'est de mettre un coup de blaster sur
le pouce en l'air qui se situe juste en
dessous de cette vidéo si vous l'avez
aimée de vous abonner
si c'est pas déjà fait et puis n'hésitez
pas à me dire dans les commentaires s'il
ya d'autres conseils que vous aimeriez
donner aux autres membres de la
communauté
moi je vous dis rester curieux et à très
bientôt pour une prochaine vidéo on est
en 2021 ça y est cette année pourrie
elle est passée et je vous souhaite une
merveilleuse année 2020 plein de projets
pleins de vidéos plein de bonnes choses
à vous tous je vous remercie d'être de
plus en plus nombreux sur cette chaîne
sur discorde sur un star sur sur
facebook voilà vous êtes l'arrêt c'est
très très cool et je passe de plus en
plus de temps avec vous et j'apprécie
vraiment c'est cool merci